he's supposed to be very glad yeah I
hope you like it
this is assumption of our one last
service core professional Russian was
suspended and it's bit for short time
after revolted this is a very wonderful
place
the hour is become there was once was
the CEO of was of once was world largest
Bitcoin exchange it was an exchange that
collapse in 2014 after the happy party
650,000 bitcoins
in 2015 our guest speaker was arrested
in Japan for 1400 month without fail on
three criminal charges and last year he
was found not guilty of the charges and
this is a rarity in Japan where post
indictment
completion rates are 99 percent
percentage but he was found guilty of
one charge for which he received a
suspended sentence parties he has
appeared
and during the last period of
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my clients for the hosting
service asked if I if that time could
pay in Bitcoin
and that's it that's it over this
exchange initially there were only a few
thousand clients from mountaintops when
I took over in three months the client
way through to 60,000 people clients and
then in two years to 1 million clients
so the company wanna buy traffic in the
company
[Music]
[Music]
since then before and after I since I
had a lot of experience looking at
global currency and thinking about what
could have been done and what cannot be
what could be done and what cannot be
done with personal currency and what's
lacking in that space
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bitcoins were invented in 2009 usually
an away means of settlements eventually
the purpose of the goal of usage of big
clients first chips of bitcoins evolved
from pure settlement mechanism to more
of an investment on mechanism and
therefore no wormholes crypto assets
than rather than encryption
[Music]
however I believe the value of bitcoins
is more of its nature and cryptocurrency
rather than a crypto asset and
settlements means or payment methods
become more important in the world in
general as we as time goes by and I
believe using Mississippi's blockchain
and others camp is not fully realized
and therefore I believe that rather than
investment it should be more of our
payment
[Music]
that's one of the reasons why I wrote
this book I wanted to I wish to explore
what can be done with cryptocurrency
riff by reflecting on what has been
achieved from the currency so far one of
the issues that remained with parents
and trustee to seek more value in
cryptocurrency
right now extends it is still not very
practical it is difficult to exchange in
a safe
in Japan are the currency their various
methods for payment credit cards for
example you drive a taxi credit cards
obviously can be used but also they are
emoney
on such a sitcom and anything that's QR
code base and there is an increase of
such means and in total I believe there
are about seven different ways of
payment and medically luck then in line
are all dedicated or dedicated or
invested in a payment method so meaning
that cryptocurrencies as competitions
[Music]
what goner is much attention about
cryptocurrency is the fact that devalue
its value which drastically go up and
down the fact that exchanges have
defaulted that's more in the news but
industry in industry is working hard to
enhance the value of club from the
currency of the payment methods and
issues are being increased in Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies share a major
challenge or barrier which is pressing
when this point the currency is captain
this value goes up and that is fine but
when it goes down is a problem
[Music]
[Music]
another issued for a cryptocurrency for
it to become widely available while the
use is an issue of security
how to store store cryptocurrency and
secure manner is a major challenge
though there are various ways that just
cold wallet or using cell phone the
using Hardware security of keys to
secure a to store a cryptocurrency in a
secure manner is too so difficult and
that issue has to be resolved
there are less visible challenges as
well but one has to do with again
security which I will talk about a
little later but big points and other
alternatives are all or use an
encryption method or ECDSA which is a
method that's locked in not easy to
change therefore and if there are
security issues inherent in a as well it
would be a challenge to change
there's something called approval work
which would using almost extraordinary
amounts of electricity in terms if it's
a country it would be brag number forty
terms of electricity usage and it is not
necessary electricity is used not for
the function but tonality of the
cryptocurrency but simply procedure
also look for more Couture logic you
ain't no security key oh so no matter
what economic case you the selector city
from people it's their other on
mechanisms other than proof-of-work but
so far mechanism that would be a future
challenge
[Music]
I've been thinking investigating these
issues
I will take time to resolve them and
another fact is that to to develop the
IT industry or the the engineering
skills itself here in Japan is important
for me Japan used to be engineering
superpower in terms of for example the
quality of its pcs for right now taking
cloud for example is the u.s. that
dominates
yeah
so now I work with a company system
technology is right now in terms of
computing its Amazon Google and
Microsoft dominate three companies
essentially all based all based in the
US and I want Japan to be on the
playing field and that's why Christine
technologies is working on cloud
solutions operating systems and other
technologies for the future
[Music]
mr. car policy must enjoy being a man
again sorry you got John Harris
automobile magazine you must enjoy being
a free man again
one wonders do you it sounds like you
intend to stay in Japan are you do you
have a permanent residence here you know
having been through this criminal
conviction you have the opportunity to
the stage
I do not have women residency i regular
visa they're subject to renewal from
time to time I think that's the case
Patrick
one day I would like to hold for a
minute
[Music]
but right now I have no problem
your goddamn associative dress what is
your status of your legal process right
now on your ceiling you set that
cryptocurrency told me personally
interview that cryptocurrencies are very
risky it's like ten thousand people that
while they're dancing or out lunch
merits okay but when everybody wants to
sit down it's like a big mess and then
now you're kind of pushing it what's
happening to it back and are you rich
now and why are you speaking in Japanese
English
vitamin E national study game Oh
children stayed in Akutan our geometry
data solution in man who should collect
a turtle you know do you put on a
negotiating process circle of animosity
that is a most efficient path there's
nothing
so regarding the obstacles I guess you
mean regarding the criminal charges for
which the G they are much more much
their method or nobody's person you
can't step up to the coaches
[Music]
[Music]
my misspent secret is
[Music]
[Music]
so the issue is not from us but I
understand the risk well despite the
risk anyway but if you want to go
somewhere it will take cryptocurrencies
make possible
[Music]
[Music]
money never mooned Isaac Rockets Attica
Conway Association America it is
I mean
today
[Music]
[Music]
they must come in the sacristy
michio kaku which then you didn't also
know that snobs ago guy so you know what
I mean you know Mikey type open these
stories ability box in sambuca Java is
recording
sorry discussions of publishing the
translation
this is the foreign correspondence
problem in a while
Richard Castle at a just one us question
about your here I think given as kind of
insanely the rate of convictions in
Japan that's certain surprise that you
were acquitted of two charges and there
was maybe it was a sense of your
reasoning behind that and you're
concerned that reopening the case could
land you in further legal hot water and
a second question if I may you're not
the only high profile French business
person to have some Japanese legal
problems at the moment we've all been
waiting about the Japanese legal system
and conditions in prisons vertical mr.
Cohen well if you could give us a flavor
of the conditions you felt during your
time in prison and whether you have any
advice for mr. Guerin I mean you you
beat the system so what would you say
[Music]
[Music]
- Seneca otherwise
sit down mr. big when you know what
there's no peace no intimacy I think I
thought in the first issue I think it'd
be better I would speak